I'm sure that the nominees will be very  grateful if I get this over with quickly  so for the best department of  performance by an actor in a supporting  role the nominees are Ed Begley in sweet  bird of youth Victor Buono and whatever  happened to Baby Jane Telly Savalas and  Birdman of Alcatraz Omar Sharif in  Lawrence of Arabia and Terence Stamp and  Billy Burton may have the only and the  winner is that  I'm not Ed Begley  I'm a long way from Hartford Connecticut  I want to thank Andrew Berman  first of course without him I wouldn't  be in the picture but I owe a great  great deal of thanks to Richard Brooks  man for whom I had worked before a  firing director but most of all and this  is from the heart my agent George Morris  really and truly this man had faith in  me that I didn't have myself I never  dreamed I would get that part but he had  faith in me and he kept after it and I  got it thank you very very much